independent senator angus King is a
member of the Senate Intelligence
Committee he's with us now from
Brunswick Maine senator good morning
good morning charlie glad to be with you
let me begin with this what do you
expect to hear hope to hear a plan to
ask the Attorney General about when he
appears before the Senate Intelligence
Committee there there are several things
we want to look at one is he was
certainly a member of the Trump campaign
what were his contacts if any with with
Russian officials during the during the
period of the campaign I think that's
that's certainly a question that we need
to ask secondly a question I'm
interested in is what role did he play
if any again in the Comey firing because
at that point he was supposed to be
recused from this investigation have
nothing to do with it and to the extent
the Comey firing had something to do
with the investigation I think that's an
area that we need to explore
that's exactly right we heard James
Comey raised concerns about the Attorney
General's dealings with Russian
officials do you believe there might
have been a third meeting one or some of
these concerns well I I don't want to
comment on that
as you know mr. Comey director Comey
said we need to talk about some of these
things in closed session so I can't
confirm whether there were other
meetings I think that's obviously one of
the things we want to ask mister
sessions and and by the way my
inclination is that this should be in an
open session the only reason you go into
a closed session as if it's national
security and I don't believe we're
talking about national security issues
here if we get into national security
issues we can cut off that line of
questioning and defer it to a closed
session but I my my starting point is
that the American people need to
understand this whole issue and the more
of these sessions we can have in public
the better senator King how is all of
this sitting with you you know we've had
time now to digest what director Comey
said when you have time to take it all
in and process it how is it sitting with
you and what concerns you now going
forward how do we advance this
investigation well what worries me about
this and about all the drama surrounding
the testimony last week is that I
wouldn't say it's a
version because it's certainly an
important issue but the real issue here
is what the Russians did they attacked
us this was a really serious
sophisticated long-term they knew what
they were doing and not only did they
you know get into emails and release
emails and try to influence the election
they were also poking and prodding in
state election systems and they're going
to be back why hasn't the President of
the United States responsible for the
national security of the United States
spoke out in the same way that you have
in James Comey has well I have to tell
you Charlie that I thought that was one
of the most disturbing moments in the
hearing with James Comey last week was
when Joe Manchin of West Virginia asked
him that question in those nine
interactions with the president did he
ever express any interest in what the
Russians did how they did it how we know
they did it what their plans are and the
answer was no zero and that's very
disturbing and as you know the president
has sort of denigrated this whole idea
from the very beginning and and it it
it's it's really worrisome I can
understand his concern about whether his
campaign was involved and whether he's
implicated that's that's certainly you
know understandable but on the other
hand he's the commander in chief and the
country's under attack and he's acting
like you know it's all personal this is
this is a serious matter and I wish he
would sit down with the intelligence
community and really absorb what was
done here and the significance of it mr.
King thank you so much for joining us
this morning from Maine pleasure to be
with you